[Music]
introductory note
the following very singular narrative or
record of impressions
was discovered under circumstances so
extraordinary that they deserve
careful description on the evening of
wednesday
august 27 1913 at about 8 30
the population of the small seaside
village of podawanket maine usa
was aroused by a thunderous report
accompanied by a blinding flash
and persons near the shore beheld a
mammoth ball of fire
dart from the heavens into the sea but a
short distance out
sending up a prodigious column of water
the following sunday
a fishing party composed of john
richmond peter b
carr and simon canfield caught in their
trawl
and dragged ashore a mass of metallic
rock
weighing 360 pounds and looking as mr
canfield
said like a piece of slag most of the
inhabitants agreed that this heavy body
was none other than the fireball which
had fallen from the sky
four days before and dr richard m jones
the local scientific authority
allowed that it must be an aerolite or
meteoric stone
in chipping off specimens to send to an
expert boston analyst
dr jones discovered embedded in the
semi-metallic mass
the strange book containing the ensuing
tale
which is still in his possession in form
the discovery resembles an
ordinary notebook about five by three
inches in size
and containing 30 leaves in material
however it presents marked peculiarities
the covers are apparently of some dark
stony substance
unknown to geologists and unbreakable by
any mechanical means
no chemical reagent seems to act upon
them the leaves are much the same
save that they are lighter in color and
so infinitely thin as to be quite
flexible
the hole is bound by some process not
very clear to those who have observed it
a process involving the adhesion of the
leaf substance to the cover substance
these substances cannot now be separated
nor can the leaves be torn by any amount
of force
the writing is greek of the purest
classical quality
and several students of paleography
declare that the characters are in a
cursive hand
used about the 2nd century bc
there is little in the text to determine
the date
the mechanical mode of writing cannot be
deduced beyond the fact that it must
have resembled
that of the modern slate and slate
pencil
during the course of analytical efforts
made by the late professor chambers of
harvard
several pages mostly at the conclusion
of the narrative
were blurred to the point of utter
effacement before being read
a circumstance forming a well-nigh
irreparable loss
what remains of the contents was done
into modern greek letters by the
paleographer rutherford
and in this form submitted to the
translators
professor mayfield of the massachusetts
institute of technology
who examined samples of the strange
stone declares it a true meteorite
an opinion in which dr von winterfeldt
of heidelberg
interned in 1918 as a dangerous enemy
alien
does not concur professor bradley of
columbia college
adopts a less dogmatic ground pointing
out that certain utterly unknown
ingredients are present in large
quantities
and warning that no classification is as
yet possible
the presence nature and message of the
strange book form so momentous a problem
that no explanation can even be
attempted
the text as far as preserved is here
rendered as literally as our language
permits
in the hope that some reader may
eventually hit upon an interpretation
and solve one of the greatest scientific
mysteries of recent years
it was a narrow place and i was alone
on one side beyond a margin of vivid
waving green
was the sea blue bright and billowy
and sending up vaporous exhalations
which intoxicated me
so profuse indeed were these exhalations
that they gave me an odd
impression of a coalescence of sea and
sky for the heavens were likewise bright
and blue
on the other side was the forest ancient
almost as the sea itself
and stretching infinitely inland it was
very
dark for the trees were grotesquely huge
and luxuriant
and incredibly numerous their giant
trunks were of a horrible green which
blended weirdly with the narrow green
tract where on ice stood
at some distance away on either side of
me the strange forest extended down to
the water's edge
obliterating the shoreline and
completely hemming in the narrow tract
some of the trees i observed stood in
the water itself
as though impatient of any barrier to
their progress
i saw no living thing nor sign that any
living thing
save myself had ever existed the sea
in the sky and the wood encircled me and
reached off into regions beyond my
imagination
nor was there any sound save of the wind
tossed wood
and of the sea as i stood in this silent
place
i suddenly commenced to tremble for
though i knew not how i came there
and could scarce remember what my name
and rank had been
i felt that i should go mad if i could
understand what lurked about me
i recalled things i had learned things i
had dreamed
things i had imagined and yearned for in
some other distant life i thought of
long nights when i had gazed up at the
stars of heaven
and cursed the gods that my free soul
could not traverse the vast abysses
which were inaccessible to my body
i conjured up ancient blasphemies and
terrible delvings into the papers of
democritus
but as memories appeared i shuddered in
deeper fear
for i knew that i was alone horribly
alone
alone yet close to sentient impulses of
vast vague kind
which i prayed never to comprehend nor
encounter
in the voice of the swaying green
branches i fancied i could detect a kind
of malignant hatred and demonic triumph
sometimes they struck me as being in
horrible colloquy with ghastly and
unthinkable things
which the scaly green bodies of the
trees half-hid
hid from sight but not from
consciousness
the most oppressive of my sensations was
a sinister feeling of alienage
though i saw about me objects which i
could name trees
grass sea and sky i felt that their
relation to me was not the same
as that of the trees grass sea and sky i
knew in another
and dimly remembered life the nature of
the difference i could not yet tell
yet i shook in stark fright as it
impressed itself upon me
and then in a spot where i had before
discerned nothing but the misty sea
i beheld the green meadow separated from
me by a vast expanse
of blue rippling water with sun-tipped
wavelets yet strangely near
often i would peep fearfully over my
right shoulder at the trees
but i preferred to look at the green
meadow which affected me oddly
it was while my eyes were fixed upon
this singular tract
that i first felt the ground in motion
beneath me
beginning with a kind of throbbing
agitation which held a fiendish
suggestion of conscious action
the bit of bank on which i stood
detached itself from the grassy shore
and commenced to float away borne slowly
onward as if by some current of
resistless force
i did not move astonished and startled
as i was by the unprecedented phenomenon
but stood rigidly still until a wide
lane of water yawned between me and the
land of trees
then i sat down in a sort of daze and
again looked at the sun-tipped water
and the green meadow behind me the trees
and the things they may have been hiding
seemed to radiate
infinite menace this i knew without
turning to view them
for as i grew more used to the scene i
became less and less dependent upon the
five senses that once had been my sole
reliance
i knew the green scaly forest hated me
yet now i was safe from it for my bit of
bank had drifted far from the shore
but though one peril was passed another
loomed up before me pieces of earth were
constantly crumbling from the floating
isle which held me
so that death could not be far distant
in any event
yet even then i seemed to sense that
death would be death to me no more
for i turned again to watch the green
meadow imbued with a curious feeling of
security
in strange contrast to my general horror
then it was that i heard at a distance
immeasurable
the sound of falling water not that of
any trivial cascades such as i had known
but that which might be heard in the
farsithian lands if all the
mediterranean were poured down an
unfathomable abyss it was toward this
sound that my shrinking island was
drifting
yet i was content far in the rear were
happening weird and terrible things
things which i turned to view yet
shivered to behold
for in the sky dark vaporous forms
hovered fantastically
brooding over trees and seeming to
answer the challenge of the waving green
branches
then a thick mist arose from the sea to
join the sky forms
and the shore was erased from my sight
though the sun
what sun i knew not shone brightly on
the water around me
the land i had left seemed involved in a
demonic tempest were dashed the will of
the hellish trees and what they hid
with that of the sky and the sea and
when the mist vanished
i saw only the blue sky and the blue sea
for the land and the trees were no more
it was at this point that my attention
was arrested by the singing
in the green meadow hitherto as i have
said
i had encountered no sign of human life
but now
there arose to my ears a dull chant
whose origin and nature were apparently
unmistakable
while the words were utterly
indistinguishable the chant awakened in
me a peculiar train of associations
and i was reminded of some vaguely
disquieting lines i had once translated
out of an egyptian book
which in turn were taken from a papyrus
of ancient marrow
through my brain ran lines that i fear
to repeat
lines telling of very antique things and
forms of life in the days when our earth
was exceedingly young
of things which thought and moved and
were alive
yet which gods and men would not
consider alive
it was a strange book as i listened i
became gradually conscious of a
circumstance which had before puzzled me
only subconsciously
at no time had my sight distinguished
any definite objects in the green meadow
an impression of vivid homogeneous
verger being the sum total of my
perception
now however i saw that the current would
cause my island to pass the shore
at but a little distance so that i might
learn more of the land and of the
singing thereon
my curiosity to behold the singers had
mounted high
though it was mingled with apprehension
bits of sod continued to break away from
the tiny tract which carried me
but i heeded not their loss for i felt
that i was not to die with the body
or appearance of a body which i seemed
to possess
that everything about me even life and
death was illusory
that i had overleaped the bounds of
mortality and corporeal entity
becoming a free detached thing impressed
me as almost certain
of my location i knew nothing saved that
i felt i could not be on the earth
planet
once so familiar to me my sensations
apart from a kind of haunting terror
were those of a traveler
just embarked upon an unending voyage of
discovery
for a moment i thought of the lands and
persons i had left behind
and of strange ways whereby i might
someday tell them of my adventurings
even though i might never return i had
now floated very near the green meadow
so that the voices were clear and
distinct but though i knew many
languages
i could not quite interpret the words of
the chanting
familiar they indeed were as i had
subtly felt when at a greater distance
but beyond a sensation of vague and
awesome remembrance
i could make nothing of them a most
extraordinary quality in the voices
a quality which i cannot describe at
once frightened and fascinated me
my eyes could now discern several things
amidst the omnipresent virgin rocks
covered with bright grain moss shrubs of
considerable height
and less definable shapes of great
magnitude which seem to move or vibrate
amidst the shrubbery in a peculiar way
the chanting whose authors i was so
anxious to glimpse
seemed loudest at points where these
shapes were most numerous and most
vigorously in motion
and then as my island drifted closer and
the sound of the distant waterfall grew
louder
i saw clearly the source of the chanting
and in one horrible instant
remembered everything of such things i
cannot
i dare not tell for therein was revealed
the hideous solution
of all which had puzzled me and that
solution would drive you mad
even as it almost drove me i knew now
the change through which i had passed
and through which certain others who
once were men had passed
and i knew the endless cycle of the
future which none like me may escape
i shall live forever be conscious
forever
though my soul cries out to the gods for
the boon of death
and oblivion all is before me
beyond the deafening torrent lies the
land of stetholos
where young men are infinitely old the
green meadow
i will send a message across the
horrible immeasurable abyss
at this point the text becomes illegible
the little village of saint faith's
nestles in a hollow of wooded till
up on the north bank of the river fawn
in the country of hampshire
huddling close round its grey norman
church as if for spiritual protection
against the phase and fairies
the trolls and little people who might
be supposed still to linger in the vast
empty spaces of the new forest
and to come after dusk and do their
doubtful businesses
once outside the hamlet you may walk in
any direction
so long as you avoid the high road which
leads to brockenhurst
for the length of a summer afternoon
without seeing sign of human habitation
or possibly even catching sight of
another human being
shaggy wild ponies may stop their
feeding for a moment as you pass
the white scuts of rabbits will vanish
into their burrows
a brown viper perhaps will glide from
your path into a clump of heather
and unseen birds will chuckle in the
bushes but it may easily happen that for
a long day you will see nothing human
but you will not feel in the least
lonely in summer at any rate
the sunlight will be gay with
butterflies and the air thick with all
those woodland sounds which like
instruments and an orchestra
combine to play the great symphony of
the yearly festival of june
winds whisper in the birches and sigh
among the furs
bees are busy with their retilent labor
among the heather
myriad birds chirp in the green temples
of the forest trees
and the voice of the river prattling
over stony places
bubbling into pools chuckling and
gulping around corners
gives you the sense that many presences
and companions are near at hand
yet oddly enough though one would have
thought that these benign and cheerful
influences of wholesome
air and spaciousness of forest were very
healthful comrades for a man
insofar as nature can really influence
this wonderful human genus
which has in these centuries learned to
defy her most violent storms
in its well-established houses to bridle
her torrents and make them light at
streets to tunnel her mountains and plow
her seas
the inhabitants of saint faiths will not
willingly venture into the forest after
dark
for in spite of the silence and
loneliness of the hooded knight
it seems that a man is not sure in what
company he may suddenly find himself
and though it is difficult to get from
these villagers any very clear story of
occult appearances
the feeling is widespread one story
indeed i have heard with some
definiteness
the tale of a monstrous goat that has
been seen to skip with hellish glee
about the woods and shady places
and this perhaps is connected with the
story which i have here attempted to
piece together
it too is well known to them for all
remember the young artist who died here
not long ago
a young man or so he struck the beholder
of great personal beauty
with something about him that made men's
faces to smile and brighten when they
looked on him
his ghost they will tell you walks
constantly by the stream
and through the woods which he loved so
and in a special it haunts a certain
house
the last of the village where he lived
and it's a garden in which he was done
to death
for my part i am inclined to think that
the terror of the forest
dates chiefly from that day so such as
the story is
i have set it forth in connected form it
is based partly on the accounts of the
villagers
but mainly on that of darcy a friend of
mine and a friend of the man with whom
these events were chiefly concerned
the day had been one of untarnished
midsummer splendor
and as the sun drew near to its setting
the glory of the evening grew every
moment more crystalline
more miraculous westward from saint
faith's
the beechwood which stretched for some
miles toward the heathery upland beyond
already cast its veil of clear shadow
over the red roofs of the village
but the spire of the grey church
overtopping all
still pointed a flaming orange finger
into the sky
the river fawn which runs below lay in
sheets of sky-reflected blue
and wound its dreamy devious course
round the edge of this wood
where a rough two-planked bridge crossed
from the bottom of the garden of the
last house in the village
and communicated by means of a little
wicker gate with the wood itself
then once out of the shadow of the wood
the stream lay in flaming pools of the
molten crimson of the sunset
and lost itself in the haze of woodland
distances
this house at the end of the village
stood outside the shadow
and the lawn which sloped down to the
river was still flecked with sunlight
garden beds of dazzling color lined its
gravel walks
and down the middle of it ran a brick
pergola half hidden in clusters of
rambler rose and purple with starry
clematis
at the bottom end of it between two of
its pillars was slung a hammock
containing a shirt-sleeved figure the
house itself
lays somewhat remote from the rest of
the village and a footpath leading
across two fields
now tall and fragrant with hay was its
only communication with the high road
it was low built only two stories in
height
and like the garden its walls were a
mass of flowering roses
a narrow stone terrace ran along the
garden front
over which was stretched and awning and
on the terrace a young silent-footed
manservant was busy with the laying of
the table for dinner
he was neat-handed and quick with his
job and having finished it he went back
into the house
and reappeared again with a large rough
bath towel on his arm
with this he went to the hammock and the
pergola
nearly ate sir he said has mr darcy come
yet
asked a voice from the hammock no sir
if i'm not back when he comes tell him
that i'm just having a bath before
dinner
the servant went back to the house and
after a moment or two
frank halton struggled to a sitting
posture and slipped out onto the grass
he was of medium height and rather
slender and build
but the supple ease and grace of his
movements gave the impression of great
physical strength
even his descent from the hammock was
not an awkward performance
his face and hands were a very dark
complexion either from constant exposure
to
wind and sun or as his black hair and
dark eyes tended to show
from some strain of southern blood his
head was small
his face of an exquisite beauty of
modeling while the smoothness of its
contour would have led you to believe
that he was a beardless lad still in his
teens
but something some look which living and
experience alone can give
seemed to contradict that and finding
yourself completely puzzled as to his
age
you would next moment probably cease to
think about that
and only look at this glorious specimen
of young manhood with wondering
satisfaction
he was dressed as became the season and
the heat and wore
only a shirt open at the neck and a pair
of flannel trousers
his head covered very thickly with a
somewhat rebellious crop of short curly
hair
was bare as he strolled across the lawn
to the bathing place that lay below
then for a moment there was silence then
the sound of splashed and divided
waters and presently after a great shout
of ecstatic joy
as he swam upstream with the foamed
water standing in a frill around his
neck
then after some five minutes of limb
stretching struggle with the flood
he turned over on his back and with arms
thrown wide
floated downstream ripple cradled and
inert
his eyes were shut and between
half-parted lips he talked gently to
himself
i am one with it he said to himself the
river and i
i and the river the coolness and splash
of it is i
and the water herbs that wave in it are
i also and my strength and my limbs are
not mine but the rivers
it is all one all one dear fawn
a quarter of an hour later he appeared
again at the bottom of the lawn
dressed as before his wet hair already
drying into its crisp short curls again
there he paused a moment looking back at
the stream with the smile with which men
look on the face of a friend
then turn towards the house
simultaneously his servant came to the
door leading onto the terrace
followed by a man who appeared to be
some halfway through the fourth decade
of his years
frank and he saw each other across the
bushes and garden beds
and each quickening his step they met
suddenly face to face
round an angle of the garden walk in the
fragrance of syringa
my dear darcy cried frank i'm charmed to
see you
but the other stared at him in amazement
frank
he exclaimed yes that is my name he said
laughing
what is the matter darcy took his hand
what have you done to yourself he asked
you're a boy again
i have a lot to tell you said frank lots
that you will hardly believe
but i shall convince you he broke off
suddenly
and held up his hand hush there's my
nightingale
he said the smile of recognition and
welcome with which he had greeted his
friend
faded from his face and a look of
wrapped wonder took its place
as of a lover listening to the voice of
his beloved
his mouth parted slightly showing the
white line of teeth
and his eyes looked out and out until
they seemed to darcy to be focused on
things beyond the vision of man
then something perhaps startled the bird
for the song ceased yes
lots to tell you he said really i am
delighted to see you
but you look rather white and pulled
down no wonder after that fever
and there is to be no nonsense about
this visit it is june now
you will stop here till you're fit to
begin work again two months at least
i can't trespass quite to that extent
frank took his arm and walked him down
the grass
trespass who talks of trespass i shall
tell you quite openly when i am tired of
you
but you know when we have the studio
together we use not to bore each other
however it is ill talking of going away
on the moment of your arrival
just a stroll to the river and then it
will be dinner time
darcy took out his cigarette case and
offered it to the other
frank laughed no not for me dear me i
suppose i used to smoke once
how very odd given it up i don't know
i suppose i must have anyhow i don't do
it now
i would as soon think of eating meat
another victim on the smoking altar of
vegetarianism
victim asked frank do i strike you as
such
he paused on the margin of the stream
and whistled softly
next moment a moorhen made its splashing
flight across the river
and ran up the bank frank took it very
gently in his hands and stroked its head
as the creature lay against his shirt
and is the house among the reeds still
secure
he half-crooned to it and is the missus
quite well
and are the neighbors flourishing their
dear home with you
and he flung it into the air that bird's
very tame
said darcy slightly bewildered it is
rather
said frank following its flight during
dinner frank chiefly occupied himself in
bringing himself up to date in the
movements and achievements of this old
friend whom he had not seen for six
years
those six years it now appeared had been
full of incident and success for darcy
he had made a name for himself as a
portrait painter which made fare to
outlast the vogue of a couple of seasons
and his leisure time had been brief
then some four months previously he had
been through a severe attack of typhoid
the result of which as concerns this
story
was that he had come down to this
sequestered place to recruit
yes you've got on said frank at the end
i always knew you would
ara with more in prospect money
you roll in it i suppose and oh darcy
how much happiness have you had all
these years
that is the only imperishable possession
and how much have you learned
oh i don't mean an art even i could have
done well in that
darcy laughed done well my dear fellow
all i have learned in these six years
you knew so to speak in your cradle
your old pictures fetch huge prices do
you never paint now
frank shook his head no i'm too busy he
said
doing what please tell me that is what
everyone is forever asking me
doing i suppose you would say i do
nothing
darcy glanced up but the brilliant young
face opposite him
it seems to suit you that way of being
busy he said
now it's your turn do you read do you
study
i remember you saying that it would do
us all all us artists i mean
a great deal of good if we would study
any one human face
carefully for a year without recording a
line have you been doing that
frank shook his head again i mean
exactly what i say
he said i have been doing nothing and i
have never been so occupied
look at me have i not done something to
myself to begin with
you are two years younger than i said
darcy at least you used to be
you therefore 35 but had i never seen
you before
i should say you were just 20. but was
it worthwhile to spend six years of
greatly occupied life in order to look
20 seems rather like a woman of fashion
frank laughed boisterously first time
i've ever been compared to that
particular bird of prey
he said no that has not been my
occupation
in fact i'm only very rarely conscious
that one effect of my occupation has
been that
of course it must have been if one comes
to think of it
it is not very important quite true my
body has become young
but that is very little i have become
young
darcy pushed back his chair and sat
sideways to the table looking at the
other
has that been your occupation then he
asked
yes that anyhow is one aspect of it
think what youth means
it is the capacity for growth mind body
spirit
all grow all get stronger all have a
fuller
firmer life every day that is something
considering that every day that passes
after the ordinary man reaches the
full-blown flower of his strength
weakens his hold on life a man reaches
his prime
and remains we say in his prime for 10
years or perhaps 20
but after his prime is prime is reached
he slowly
and sensibly weakens these are the signs
of age in you
in your body in your art probably in
your mind
you were less electric than you were but
i
when i reach my prime i am nearing it ah
you shall see
the stars had begun to appear in the
blue velvet of the sky
and to the east the horizon seen above
the black silhouette of the village was
growing dove-colored with the approach
of moonrise
white moths hovered dimly over the
garden beds and the footsteps of night
tiptoed through the bushes
suddenly frank rose odd is the supreme
moment he said softly
now more than at any other time the
current of life the eternal imperishable
current runs so close to me that i am
almost enveloped in it
be silent a minute he advanced to the
edge of the terrace and looked out
standing stretched with arms outspread
darcy heard him draw a long breath into
his lungs
and after many seconds expel it again
six or eight times he did this
then turned back into the lamplight it
will sound to you quite mad
i expect he said but if you want to hear
the soberest truth i have ever spoken
and shall ever speak
i will tell you about myself but come
into the garden if it is not damp for
you
i've never told anyone yet but i should
like to tell you
it is long in fact since i have even
tried to classify what i have learned
they wandered into the fragrant dimness
of the pergola and sat down
then frank began years ago do you
remember
he said we used often to talk about the
decay of joy in the world
many impulses we settled had contributed
to this decay
some of which were good in themselves
others that were quite completely bad
among the good things i put what we may
call certain christian virtues
renunciation resignation sympathy with
suffering
and the desire to relieve sufferers but
out of those things
spring very bad ones useless
renunciation
asceticism for its own sake
mortification of the flesh with nothing
to follow
no corresponding gain that is and that
awful and terrible disease which
devastated england some centuries ago
and from which by heredity of spirit we
suffer now puritanism
that was a dreadful plague the brutes
held and taught that joy and laughter
and merriment were evil
it was a doctrine the most profane and
wicked
why what is the commonest crime one sees
a sullen face
that is the truth of the matter now all
my life
i've believed that we are intended to be
happy that joy is of all gifts the most
divine
and when i left london abandoned my
career such as it was
i did so because i intended to devote my
life to the cultivation of joy
and by a continuous and unsparing effort
to be happy
among people and in constant intercourse
with others i did not find it possible
there were too many distractions and
towns and work rooms
and also too much suffering so i took
one step backwards or forwards as you
may choose to put it
and went straight to nature to trees
birds animals
to all those things which quite clearly
pursue one aim only
which blindly follow the great native
instinct to be happy
without any care at all for morality or
human law or divine law
i wanted you understand to get all joy
first-hand and unadulterated
and i think it scarcely exists among men
it is obsolete
darcy turned in his chair ah but what
makes birds and animals happy
he asked food food and mating
frank laughed gently in the stillness do
not think i became a sensualist
he said i did not make that mistake for
the sensualist carries his miseries
pick a back and round his feet as wound
the shroud that shall soon unwrap him
i may be mad it is true but i'm not so
stupid anyhow as to have tried that
no what is it that makes puppies play
with their own tails
that sends cats on their prowling
ecstatic errands at night
he paused a moment so i went to nature
he said
i sat down here in this new forest sat
down
fair and square and looked that was my
first difficulty
to sit here quiet without being bored to
wait without being impatient
to be receptive and very alert though
for a long time nothing particular
happened
the change in fact was slow in those
early stages
nothing happened asked darcy rather
impatiently
with a sturdy revolt against any new
idea which to the english mind is
synonymous with nonsense
why what in the world should happen now
frank as he had known him was the most
generous but most quick-tempered of
mortal men
in other words his anger would flare to
a prodigious beacon
under almost no provocation only to be
quenched again under a gust of no less
impulsive kindliness
thus the moment darcy had spoken an
apology for his hasty question was
halfway up his tongue
but there was no need for it to have
traveled even so far for frank laughed
again with kindly genuine mirth
oh how i should have resented that a few
years ago he said
thank goodness that resentment is one of
the things i have got rid of
i certainly wish that you should believe
my story in fact you are going to but
that you at this moment should imply
that you do not does not concern me
ah your solitary sojournings have made
you inhuman
said darcy still very english no
human said frank rather more human at
least
rather less of an ape well that was my
first quest he continued after a moment
the deliberate and unswerving pursuit of
joy and my method the eager
contemplation of nature
as far as motive went i dare say it was
purely selfish
but as far as effect goes it seems to me
about the best thing one can do for
one's fellow creatures
for happiness is more infectious than
smallpox
so as i said i sat down and waited i
looked at happy things
zealously avoided the sight of anything
unhappy and by degrees a little trickle
of the happiness of this blissful world
began to filter into me
the trickle grew more abundant and now
my dear fellow
if i could for a moment divert for me
and to you one half of the torrent of
joy that pours through me day and night
you would throw the world art everything
aside and just live
exist when a man's body dies it passes
into trees and flowers well that is what
i've been trying to do with my soul
before death the servant had brought
into the pergola
a table with siphons and spirits and it
set a lamp upon it
as frank spoke he leaned forward towards
the other and darcy
for all his matter-of-fact common sense
could have sworn that his companion's
face
shone was luminous in itself his dark
brown eyes glowed from within
the unconscious smile of a child
irradiated and transformed his face
darcy felt suddenly excited exhilarated
go on he said go on i can feel you were
somehow telling me sober truth
i dare say you are mad but i don't see
that matters
frank laughed again mad he said
yes certainly if you wish but i prefer
to call it sane
however nothing matters less than what
anybody chooses to call things
god never labels his gifts he just puts
them into our hands
just as he put animals in the garden of
eden for adam to name if he felt
disposed
so by the continual observance and study
of things that were happy
continued he i got happiness i got joy
but seeking it as i did from nature i
got much more which i did not seek
but stumbled upon originally by accident
it is difficult to explain but i will
try
about three years ago i was sitting one
morning in a place i will show you
tomorrow
it is down by the riverbank very green
dappled with shade and sun
and the river passes there through some
little clumps of reeds
well as i sat there doing nothing but
just looking and listening
i heard the sound quite distinctly of
some flute-like instrument playing a
strange unending melody
i thought at first it was some musical
yokel on the highway
and did not pay much attention but
before long the strangeness and
indescribable beauty of the tune
struck me it never repeated itself but
it never came to an end
phrase after phrase ran its sweet course
it worked gradually and inevitably up to
a climax
and having attained it it went on
another climax was reached
and another and another then with a
sudden gasp of wonder
i localized where it came from it came
from the reeds and from the sky
and from the trees it was everywhere it
was the sound of life
it was my dear darcy as the greeks would
have said
it was pan playing on his pipes the
voice of nature
it was the life melody the world melody
darcy was far too interested to
interrupt though there was a question he
would have liked to ask
and frank went on well for the moment i
was terrified
terrified with the impotent horror of
nightmare and i stopped my ears and just
ran from the place and got back to the
house
panting trembling literally in a panic
unknowingly for at that time i only
pursued joy
i had begun since i drew my joy from
nature to get in touch with nature
nature force god call it what you will
had drawn across my face
a little gossamer web of essential life
i saw that when i emerged from my terror
and i went very humbly back to where i
had heard the panpipes
but it was nearly six months before i
heard them again
why was that asked darcy surely because
i had revolted
rebelled and worst of all been
frightened for i believe that just as
there is nothing in the world which so
injures one's body is fear
so there is nothing that so much shuts
up the soul i was afraid you see
of the one thing in the world which has
real existence
no wonder its manifestation was
withdrawn
and after six months after six months
one blessed morning i heard the piping
again i wasn't afraid that time
and since then it's grown louder it's
become more constant
i now hear it often and i can put myself
into such an attitude towards nature
that the pipes will almost certainly
sound and never yet have they played the
same
tune it is always something new
something fuller
richer more complete than before what do
you mean by
such an attitude towards nature ask
darcy
i can't explain that but by translating
it into a bodily attitude
it is this frank set up for a moment
quite straight in his chair
then slowly sunk back with arms
outspread and head drooped
that he said an effortless attitude but
open
resting receptive it is just that which
you must do with your soul
then he sat up again one word more
he said and i will bore you no further
nor unless you ask me questions shall i
talk about it again you will find me in
fact
quite sane in my mode of life birds and
beasts you will see
behaving somewhat intimately to me like
that more hen
but that is all i will walk with you
ride with you
play golf with you and talk with you on
any subject you like
but i wanted you on the threshold to
know what has happened to me
and one thing more will happen he paused
again
and a slight look of fear crossed his
eyes
there will be a final revelation he said
a complete and blinding stroke which
will throw open to me once and for all
the full knowledge the full realization
and comprehension
that i am one just as you are with life
in reality there is no me no you no it
everything is part of the one and only
thing which is life
i know that that is so but the
realization of it is not yet mine
but it will be and on that day so i take
it
i shall see pan it may mean death
the death of my body that is but i don't
care
it may mean immortal eternal life lived
here and now and forever
then having gained that my dear darcy i
shall preach such a gospel of joy
showing myself as the living proof of
the truth that puritanism
the dismal religion of sour faces shall
vanish like a breath of smoke
and be dispersed and disappear in the
sunlit air
but first the full knowledge must be
mine darcy watched his face
narrowly you're afraid of that moment he
said
frank smiled at him quite true you were
quick to have seen that
but when it comes i hope i shall not be
afraid
some little time there was silence then
darcy rose
you've bewitched me you extraordinary
boy he said
you've been telling me a fairy story and
i find myself saying
promise me it is true i promise you that
said the other and i know i shan't sleep
added darcy frank looked at him with a
sort of mild wonder as if he scarcely
understood
well what does that matter he said i
assure you it does i'm wretched unless i
sleep
of course i can make you sleep if i want
said frank in a rather bored voice
well do very good go to bed
i'll be upstairs in ten minutes frank
busied
himself for a little after the other had
gone moving the table back under the
awning of the veranda
and quenching the lamp then he went with
his quick silent tread upstairs and into
darcy's room
the ladder was already in bed but very
wide-eyed and wakeful
and frank with an amused smile of
indulgence as for a fretful child
sat down on the edge of the bed look at
me
he said and darcy looked the birds are
sleeping in the break
said frank softly and the winds are
asleep
the sea sleeps and the tides are but the
heaving of its breast
the stars swing slow rocked in the great
cradle of the heavens
he stopped suddenly gently blew out
darcy's candle
and left him sleeping morning
brought to darcy a flood of hard common
sense as clear and crisp as the sunshine
that filled his room
slowly as he woke he gathered together
the broken threads of the memories of
the evening which had ended
so he told himself in a trick of common
hypnotism
that accounted for it all the whole
strange talk he had had was under a
spell of suggestion
from the extraordinary vivid boy who had
once been a man
all his own excitement his acceptance of
the incredible
had been merely the effect of a stronger
more potent will
imposed on his own how strong that will
was
he guessed from his own instantaneous
obedience to frank's suggestion of sleep
and armed with impenetrable common sense
he came down to breakfast
frank had already begun and was
consuming a large plateful of porridge
and milk with the most prosaic and
healthy appetite slept well
he asked yes of course where did you
learn hypnotism
by the side of the river you talked an
amazing quantity of nonsense last night
remarked darcy and a voice prickly with
reason
rather i felt quite giddy look i
remembered to order a dreadful daily
paper for you
you can read about money markets or
politics or cricket matches
darcy looked at him closely in the
morning light frank looked even fresher
younger more vital than he had done the
night before and the sight of him
somehow dented darcy's armor of common
sense
you were the most extraordinary fellow i
ever saw he said
i want to ask you some more questions
ask away
said frank for the next day or two darcy
plied his friend with many questions
objections and criticisms on the theory
of life and gradually got out of him a
coherent and complete account of his
experience
in brief then frank believed that by
lying naked
as he put it to the force which controls
the passage of the stars
the breaking of a wave the budding of a
tree the love of a youth and a maiden
he had succeeded in a way hitherto
undreamed of in possessing himself of
the essential principle of life
day by day so he thought he was getting
nearer to
and in closer union with the great power
itself which caused
all life to be the spirit of nature a
force or the spirit of god
for himself he confessed to what others
would call paganism
it was sufficient for him that there
existed a principle of life
he did not worship it he did not pray to
it he did not praise it
some of it existed in all human beings
just as it existed in trees and animals
to realize and make living to himself
the fact that it was all one
was his sole aim and object here perhaps
darcy would put in a word of warning
take care he said to see pan meant death
did it not frank's eyebrows would rise
at this
what does that matter he said true the
greeks were always right and they said
so
but there is another possibility for the
nearer i get to it the more living the
more vital and young i become
what then do you expect the final
revelation will do for you
i've told you said he it will make me
immortal
but it was not so much from speech and
argument that darcy grew to grasp his
friend's conception
as from the ordinary conduct of his life
they were passing for instance one
morning down the village street
when an old woman very bent and decrepit
but with an extraordinary cheerfulness
of face
hobbled out from her cottage frank
instantly stopped when he saw her
you old darling how goes it all he said
but she did not answer her dim old eyes
were riveted on his face
she seemed to drink in like a thirsty
creature the beautiful radiance which
shown there
suddenly she put her two withered old
hands on his shoulders
you're just the sunshine itself she said
and he kissed her
and passed on but scarcely a hundred
yards further
a strange contradiction of such
tenderness occurred
a child running along the path towards
them fell on his face
and set up a dismal cry of fright and
pain
a look of horror came into frank's eyes
and putting his fingers in his ears
he fled at full speed down the street
and did not pause till he was out of
hearing
darcy having ascertained that the child
was not really hurt followed him in
bewilderment
are you without pity then he asked
frank shook his head impatiently can't
you see
he asked can't you understand that that
sort of thing
pain anger anything unlovely throws me
back
slows the coming of the great hour
perhaps when it comes i shall be able to
piece that side of life onto the other
onto the true religion of joy at present
i can't
but the old woman was she not ugly
frank's radiance gradually returned ah
no
she was like me she longed for joy and
knew it when she saw it the old darling
another question suggested itself then
what about christianity
ask darcy i can't accept it i can't
believe in any creed of which the
central doctrine
is that god who is joy should have had
to suffer
perhaps it was so in some inscrutable
way i believe it may have been so
but i don't understand how it was
possible so i leave it alone
my affair is joy they had come to the
weir above the village
and the thunder of riotous cool water
was heavy in the air
trees dipped into the translucent stream
with slender trailing branches
and the meadow where they stood was
starred with mid-summer blossomings
larks shot up caroling into the crystal
dome of blue
and a thousand voices of june sang round
them
frank bare-headed as was his want with
his coat slung over his arm and his
shirt sleeves rolled up above the elbow
stood there like some beautiful wild
animal with eyes half
shut and mouth half open drinking in the
scented warmth of the air
then suddenly he flung himself face
downwards on the grass at the edge of
the stream
burying his face in the daisies and cow
slips and lay stretch there in
wide-armed ecstasy
with his long fingers pressing and
stroking the dewy herbs of the field
never before had darcy seen him thus
fully possessed by his idea
his caressing fingers his half-buried
face pressed close to the grass
even the clothed lines of his figure
were instinct with a vitality that
somehow was different from that of other
men
and some faint glow from it reached
darcy some thrill
some vibration from that charged
recumbent body passed to him
and for a moment he understood as he had
not understood before
despite his persistent questions and the
candid answers they received
how real and how realized by frank his
idea was
then suddenly the muscles in frank's
neck became stiff and alert
and he half raised his head the panpipes
he whispered close oh so close
very slowly as if a sudden movement
might interrupt the melody
he raised himself and leaned on the
elbow of his bent arm
his eyes opened wider the lower lids
drooped as if he focused his eyes on
something very far away
and the smile on his face broadened and
quivered like sunlight on still water
till the exultance of its happiness was
scarcely human so he remained motionless
and wrapped for some minutes
then the look of listening died from his
face and he bowed his head
satisfied ah that was good he said
how is it possible you did not hear oh
you poor fellow
did you really hear nothing a week of
this outdoor and stimulating life
did wonders and restoring to darcy the
vigor and health which his weeks of
fever had felched from him
and as his normal activity and higher
pressure of vitality returned he seemed
to himself to fall
even more under the spell which the
miracle of frank's youth cast over him
twenty times a day he found himself
saying to himself suddenly at the end of
some ten minutes silent resistance to
the absurdity of frank's idea
but it isn't possible it can't be
possible and from the fact of his having
to assure himself so frequently of this
he knew that he was struggling and
arguing with a conclusion which already
had taken root in his mind
for in any case a visible living miracle
confronted him
since it was equally impossible that
this youth this boy
trembling on the verge of manhood was 35
yet such was the fact july was ushered
in by a couple of days of blustering and
fretful rain
and darcy unwilling to risk a chill kept
to the house
but to frank this weeping change of
weather seemed to have no bearing on the
behavior of the man
and he spent his days exactly as he did
under the suns of june
lying in his hammock stretched on the
dripping grass or making huge rambling
excursions into the forest
the birds hopping from tree to tree
after him to return in the evening
drenched and soaked but with the same
unquenchable flame of joy burning within
him
catch cold he would ask i've forgotten
how to do it
i think i suppose it makes one's body
more sensible always to sleep outdoors
people who live indoors always remind me
of something peeled and skinless
do you mean to say you slept out of
doors last night in that deluge
asked darcy and where may i ask frank
thought a moment
i slept in the hammock till nearly dawn
he said for i remember the light blinked
in the east when i awoke
then i went where did i go oh yes to the
meadow where the panpipe sounded so
close a week ago
you were with me do you remember but i
always have a rug if it's wet
and he went whistling upstairs somehow
that little touch
his obvious effort to recall where he
had slept brought strangely home to
darcy the wonderful romance of which he
was the still half incredulous beholder
sleep till close on dawn in a hammock
then the [ __ ] or probably scamper
underneath the windy and weeping heavens
to the remote and lonely meadow by the
weir
the picture of other such knights rose
before him
frank sleeping perhaps by the bathing
place under the filtered twilight of the
stars
or the white blaze of moonshine a stir
an awakening at some dead hour
perhaps a space of silent wide-eyed
thought and then a wandering through the
hushed woods to some other dormitory
alone with his happiness alone with the
joy and the life that suffused and
enveloped him
without other thought or desire or aim
except the hourly and never ceasing
communion with the joy of nature
they were in the middle of dinner that
night talking on in different subjects
when darcy suddenly broke off in the
middle of a sentence
i've got it he said at last i've got it
i congratulate you said frank but what
the radical unsoundness of your idea it
is this
all nature from highest to lowest is
full crammed full of suffering
every living organism and nature preys
on another
yet in your aim to get close to to be
one with nature
you leave suffering altogether out you
run away from it
you refuse to recognize it and you are
waiting you say
for the final revelation frank's brow
clouded slightly
well he asked rather wearily
can't you guess then when the final
revelation will be
enjoy you are supreme i grant you that i
did not know a man could be so master of
it
you have learned perhaps practically all
that nature can teach
and if as you think the final revelation
is coming to you
it will be the revelation of horror
suffering death
pain in all its hideous forms suffering
does exist
you hate it and fear it frank held up
his hand
stop let me think he said
there was silence for a long minute that
never struck me
he said at length it is possible that
what you suggest is true
does the sight of pan mean that do you
think is it that nature
take it all together suffers horribly
suffers to a hideous inconceivable
extent
shall i be shown all the suffering he
got up and came around to where darcy
sat
if it is so so be it he said because my
dear fellow i am near
so splendidly near to the final
revelation
today the pipes have sounded almost
without pause
i have even heard the rustle in the
bushes i believe of pans coming
i have seen yes i saw today the bushes
pushed aside as if by a hand
and a piece of face not human peered
through
but i was not frightened at least i did
not run away this time
he took a turn up to the window and back
again
yes there is suffering all through he
said and i have left it all out of my
search perhaps as you say the revelation
will be that
and in that case it will be goodbye i
have gone on one line
i shall have gone too far along one road
without having explored the other
but i can't go back now i wouldn't if i
could
not a step would i retrace in any case
whatever the revelation is
it will be god i'm sure of that
the rainy weather soon passed and with
the return of the sun
darcy again joined frank in long
rambling days
it grew extraordinarily hotter and with
the fresh bursting of life
after the rain frank's vitality seemed
to blaze higher and higher
then as is the habit of the english
weather once evening clouds began to
bank themselves up in the west
the sun went down in a glare of coppery
thunder rack
and the whole earth broiling under an
unspeakable oppression and sultriness
paused and panted for the storm after
sunset the remote fires of lightning
began to wink and flicker on the horizon
but when bedtime came the storm seemed
to have moved no nearer
though a very low unceasing noise of
thunder was audible
weary and oppressed by the stress of the
day darcy fell at once into a heavy
uncomforting sleep
he woke suddenly into full consciousness
with the din of some appalling explosion
of thunder in his ears
and sat up in bed with racing heart then
for a moment as he recovered himself
from the panic land which lies between
sleeping and waking
there was silence except for the steady
hissing of rain on the shrubs outside
his window
but suddenly that silence was shattered
and shredded into fragments by a scream
from somewhere close at hand outside in
the black garden
a scream of supreme and despairing
terror
again and once again it shrilled up and
then a babble of awful words was
interjected
a quivering sobbing voice that he knew
said my god o my god
o christ and then followed a little
mocking bleeding laugh
then with silence again only the rain
hissed on the shrubs
all this was but the affair of a moment
and without pause either to put on
clothes or light a candle
darcy was already fumbling at his door
handle even as he opened it he met a
terror-stricken face outside that of the
manservant who carried a light
did you hear he asked the man's face was
bleached into a dull shining whiteness
yes sir he said it was the master's
voice
together they hurried down the stairs
and through the dining room where an
orderly table for breakfast had already
been laid
and out onto the terrace the rain for
the moment had been utterly stayed
as if the tap of the heavens had been
turned off and under the lowering black
sky
not quite dark since the moon rode
somewhere serene behind the
conglomerated thunderclouds
darcy stumbled into the garden followed
by the servant with the candle
the monstrous leaping shadow of himself
was cast before him on the lawn
lost and wandering odors of rose and
lily and damp earth were thick about him
but more pungent with some sharp and
acrid smell that suddenly reminded him
of a certain chalet in which he had once
taken refuge in the alps
in the blackness of the hazy light from
the sky and the vague tossing of the
candle behind him
he saw that the hammock in which frank
so often lay was tenanted
a gleam of white shirt was there as if a
man were sitting up in it
but across that there was an obscure
dark shadow and as he approached the
acrid odor grew more intense
he was now only some few yards away when
suddenly the black shadow seemed to jump
into the air
then came down with tappings of hard
hooves on the brick path that ran down
the pergola
and with frolicsome skippings galloped
off into the bushes
when that was gone darcy could see quite
clearly that a shirted figure sat up in
the hammock
for one moment from sheer terror of the
unseen he hung on his step
and the servant joining him they walked
together to the hammock
it was frank he was insured in trousers
only
and he sat up with braced arms for one
half second he stared at them
his face a mask of horrible contorted
terror
his upper lip was drawn back so that the
gums of the teeth appeared
and his eyes were focused not on the two
who approached him
but on something quite close to him his
nostrils were widely expanded
as if he panted for breath and terror
incarnate and repulsion and deathly
anguish
ruled dreadful lines on his smooth
cheeks and forehead
then even as they looked the bodies sank
backwards
and the ropes of the hammock wheezed and
strained
darcy lifted him out and carried him
indoors
once he thought there was a faint
convulsive stir of the limbs that lay
was so dead a weight in his arms
but when they got inside there was no
trace of life
but the look of supreme terror and agony
of fear had gone from his face
a boy tired with play but still smiling
in his sleep
was the burden he laid on the floor his
eyes had closed
and the beautiful mouth lay in smiling
curves even as when a few mornings ago
in the meadow by the weir it had
quivered to the music of the unheard
melody of pan's pipes
then they looked further frank had come
back from his bath before dinner that
night in his usual costume of shirt and
trousers only
he had not dressed and during dinner so
darcy remembered
he had rolled up the sleeves of his
shirt to above the elbow
later as they sat and talked after
dinner on the close sultriness of the
evening
he had unbuttoned the front of his shirt
to let what little breath of wind there
was
play on his skin the sleeves were rolled
up now
the front of the shirt was unbuttoned
and on his arms and on the brown skin of
his chest
were strange discolorations which grew
momentarily more clear and defined
till they saw that the marks were
pointed prince as if caused by the
hooves of some monstrous goat
that had leaped and stamped upon him
you